all your favorite the l-word cast
members are back for showtimes an
upcoming reboot generation Q and just
like the original the show will follow
the cast as they experience love
heartbreak setbacks and success in Los
Angeles before its eighth episode
premiere on December 8 stars Lisa Haley
Kate Manning and Jennifer Beals tell us
why they felt the need to continue the
l-word after its sixth season run ended
in 2009 we were slowly trying to get the
ball rolling to figure out somehow how
to bring this show back but at that time
reboots didn't exist there was it was a
movie but that didn't make sense but we
felt the void just like everyone else
did I mean oranges new black came on
eventually and that was amazing we loved
that show but we just you know where you
have a group of lesbians and they're the
center point of the storylines and
they're not the you know the B
characters and the best friends and that
you know they're and they're only
storyline is about a relationship and
right and and that was that was missing
and so thank God for reboots hi I just
watched you to introduce yourself to
five other women I'm very friendly in my
person I love you I love you to this new
generation that's leading us forward in
many ways
is completely broken the mold in terms
of how they advocate for gender identity
and how they are completely unacceptable
able that somebody puts on them that
they don't vibe with you know that they
don't accept I just I really love it I
love like all the different terms that
are coming up the different ways we
speak to people I mean I'm still
learning so much I feel like I have a
lot of catching up to do to get my
lexicon in order but but I think it's a
really exciting time that we live in and
and the show is going to start
inhabiting those areas I can't believe
he's still one she's an attractive woman
what we're excited about is because
we're also from you know an earlier
generation or are those conversations
about you know we feel like we've broken
the barriers we feel like we've marched
the streets you know and the younger
generation who's like but what look like
what we're doing for everything now and
it's such a it's such a beautiful mix
what time you have to
seven minutes Tim let's see if we could
do it and say yeah yeah
[Music]